hello the existence of adversarial
examples is a curse for AI safety
imagine you have a neural network based
person recognizer and it works well most
of the time but not for a person with
this printed t-shirt adversarial
examples are examples of data that look
very much to humans like normal data
points but neuron networks think is
something entirely different for example
look at this Panda it is a Panda right
this is also what the convolutional
neural network would say then look at
this Panda ah the neural network says
it's a gibbon and the difference between
these pictures is not even perceivable
to humans it is this noise added to the
original image which here for
visualization purposes has been enhanced
a lot but it's really just tiny so how
can it be that these very similar images
differing by only tiny pixel differences
are so so differently perceived by
neuron networks well there are some
hypothesis for that and I had the
pleasure to talk about this with David
STS an AI safety and robustness
researcher at Google deep mind we were
at the 10th heidleberg laed Forum a few
weeks ago on a boat on the nekar river
here's my discussion with
him so hello I'm here at the 10th HLF
with David schz he's a very interesting
researcher and person and I wanted to
talk to him so see what he has say in an
offline conversation you told me that
you were doing research on adversarial
defenses and you told me that it's
harder to publish research on adversar
defenses than on attacks which I find
counterintuitive so could you please
explain me why this is counterintuitive
and how this is the case um so it's a
combination of things so first of all um
the mathematical property is that it's
always easier to find a counter example
than to find a proof right so in
mathematics if I have a proof I have a
published paper and I find a counter
example that's very easy right of course
usually uh Common Sense tells us I don't
just publish a counter example I contact
people and kind of usually counter
examples lead to kind of improved proof
so you can learn something from it but
it's much easier to find the singer
counter example than to prove a
statement in its generality um and I
think that very much holds insecurity as
well it's always easier to find a
vulnerability because you only need to
find one right then to have a system and
then like in in computer science of
course or in machine learning we
empirically evaluate it but in in
security and cryptography usually want
to prove that the system is secure and
it's of course much harder so what
happened in in advel machine learning in
robustness against atel examples is that
finding attex I'm not I'm not saying
it's trivial um but once you understand
kind of the the the tools that I use the
optimization tools and so on it's
usually fairly straightforward to find
Corner cases and to build attacks that
kind of are stronger or that kind of are
less visible or whatever you're
interested in the other way around
however it's much harder because you
basically you need to train a model
where you can't find adviser samples and
and even in practice that's a bit IL
defined because you're like you have a
method to find that res all examples but
this is of course also an approximation
right you can't like you have a machine
learning model with like millions of
parameters it's not that you can find
all possible advisor samples you only
need to find one but at during training
if you want to train robust models you
of course you need to be robust to like
all possible advisor examples it's much
harder task and then on the on the on
the academic side because it was a very
new field it just also happened that
people didn't really know yet how to
properly review papers on the matter um
so security folks for example they very
new to this idea of empirically
evaluating accuracy the the machine
learning folks were very new to this
idea of of security of like having this
advisal notion and so it just happened
that in the early days it was it was and
it's of course a subjective opinion uh a
bit easier to find loopholes and find
problems with models rather than present
a method that actually that is robust
against a wide range of attacks and a
right range of problems and so I always
find it found it a bit more challenging
to work on the defense side but on the
other hand if you like the the the
reward is also a bit higher right I mean
if you find a really good defense so
back then the M lab found advis training
or even even some papers uh before them
we doing similar things but it's very
longstanding right it's still the State
ofth art whereas attacks evolved much
quicker people iterated on attacks much
quicker so it's um it's higher risk and
maybe higher reward however you'll say
it yeah this is a nice piece of History
because yeah something which is hard
defenses should be I think more
appreciated by the community than also
rewarded uh in conferences uh we heard
here at the HLF a lecture by adish
Shamir on adversarial attacks and he
presented his dimpled manifold
hypothesis I'm claiming that this is
actually going to be the decision
boundary namely it is going to be
roughly the same as the very close to
the image manifold with a small dimple
underneath the cats so that the cats
will be above and it will have a dimple
above all the guacas so that the guacas
will be on the bottom part everything at
the bottom is going to be called by the
Network guacamole everything at the top
half is going to be called the cat what
do you think of this hypothesis and are
are there any alternative hypothesis for
adversarial examples um yeah there are
quite a few hypotheses and a fun fact is
that I actually so my first two two
papers of my PhD are more or less
exactly on the same question so why do
advisor examples exist and can we kind
of find an intuitive explanation um and
so yeah I I found the talk very nice um
mainly because I mean he didn't need to
convince me because I was already
convinced by the manifold Theory I think
it's a very intuitive explanation um
maybe not why advic examples exist but
it gives us basically a mental model of
how to think about advisor examples and
in the past years a lot of Works have
built on top of this Al model and and
try to kind of use these insights to
improve defenses to make attacks more
effective and so on so I very much
enjoyed the talk also from the
perspective that he's of course a very
accomplished researcher mainly coming
from security right and I like that he
uh he kind of stood on top like in front
of like a lot of laurates a lot of young
researchers and highlighted this as an
important problem um which I think if we
would have had that 5 years ago uh there
would have been much more traction in in
advis Mission learning uh but I still
appreciate it because it also means that
that the disciplines are moving closer
together because there I mean people
realized very early on that it's like
advis machine learning or robustness
topics out of distribution and so on are
security problems nowadays of course
people are working also on poisoning
attacks uh water marking and so on uh
but in in the academic world uh
conferences journals and so on also
research groups we are still very much
separated and so for us for example it
was very difficult to to to publish in
in the security domain a very different
style of writing and so on and I think
it's a good sign that like very
prominent researchers uh kind of
realized that this will be very
important questions in the future and
also these are challenging topics that
that uh even laurates can't like solve
on the spot and I I really hope that
that it's moving closer together I mean
there are already we small conferences
and workshops that that kind of are in
the intersection but I think it's it's
great if prominent figures uh yeah
support this kind of movement and do you
think there's other notable hypothesis
or do you think the dimpled manifold
hypothesis is the one that explains most
of the phenomena and you're you're
happiest with that I mean personally I
like the manifold hypothesis I worked on
it very much so uh it's very much a bias
of of from my side um but I think part
so
hypothesis is always is a model of
what's going on we still don't know
exactly why atelic samples exist also in
images I think the the manifold
hypothesis is very natural because like
this idea of images living in a
low-dimensional manifold of of your high
dimensional pixel space is very natural
but of course now if we if we go to llms
and we think about language if we go to
crafts and so on the hypothesis might
still be valid but it might be less
intuitive and so for me a hypothesis is
always always kind of tied into what
what can we use the hypothesis to learn
something new can we apply the
hypothesis to kind of develop new
attacks new defenses whatever um so
there are alternative hypothesis um I
think um be there there is kind of this
notion of features that are kind of only
slightly correlated with your um with
your how to say with your targets and
there's this notion that you have uh
useful features and you have features by
chance right it just happens that
specific pixels in this finite data set
happen to correlate with your target but
it's not really it's not really what you
want to learn classic example is
Envision people work on on these biases
that you in if you see birds always in
front of water you pick up on the water
and not on the bird right so and you can
you can have a similar notion of of this
happening and this being exploited by
advic samples so and this is just one
example so I think there are alternative
hypothesis and I think all of some of
them are useful in different respects
and uh for example this hypothesis very
much informed how today we think about
proper generalization in computer vision
there are data sets that now test this
problem right we have in the training
set we have water Birds on land and land
Birds on water and then at test time we
strip it right we just you can see it as
like an an advisal way of testing um and
and for this line of work like these
these alternative hypothesis were very
influential um I think in Advil bons I
think the manifold hypothesis was still
more influential than others but this
this very much depends on what people
are working on and I think I always
believe the more hypothesis the better
and of course there are some hypothesis
that you can find counter examples but
in the
end we have still a very poor
understanding of of like these very deep
models and I think with like these
really huge foundational models it's not
getting better so I think um I think
there's a lot to explore both from the
Practical and the theoretical side okay
thanks a a lot I conducted this
interview at the 10th HLF which is short
for Heidelberg laured Forum the HLF is
an annual Gathering of 200 young
researchers from math and computer
science and laits of the most
prestigious Awards in these two Fields
such as the touring award the fields
medal the abble prize and so on I
attended the last year's HLF as a young
researcher and this year as a press
member the best things for me at the HLF
Remain the ly coffee breaks and social
events at incredible occasions such as
the Spire Museum of Technology or the
boat on the NECA River on which we were
on the interview which you've just seen
on this video and I hope you have found
this discussion with David schuts about
adversarial attacks and defenses as
interesting as Miss Coffee Bean did we
both hope to see you next time so
subscribe okay bye last question will
you attend the HLF again do you plan to
uh well I mean the main question is not
will I or or do I want to um but can I
or am I allowed to um so this year so I
was last time here in9 as a PhD student
and obviously I could come back
officially as a postt talk yeah so I
definitely I I I think it's still not
well known the HLF especially
International but all people I meet
during my PhD during my postu I always
say as long as you can apply right I
mean there's no guarantee that that you
can that you are taking and that you
have have the privilege to come but I
mean there's no doesn't hurt to apply
and you can apply every year as long as
you qualify as I think couple of years
after your PhD so yeah please apply
thanks a lot this was a really cool
motivational speech and I hope this will
bear fruit so yeah thanks again for
talking to me and uh have a great HLF
yeah thank
[Music]
you